It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
It's Wednesday!
The middle of the week.
It's also our 145th episode!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for waking up early to join us here today!
Wow!
But those Ruffians that are joining us today for the first time!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
You haven't forgotten, right?
Yeah!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Now, you know what I'm gonna say, right?
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Ruffians already did the hashtag.
Hashtag.
BAU BAU!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
Good morning!
She said the thing.
What thing did I say?
I said a lot of things.
I said the thing.
You know which one of us said the thing.
BAU BAU!
It's a new morning, Moco-chan!
How are we gonna start the day off today?
Right?
On the right paw.
Thank you.
That was the answer.
The wrong paw.
Wrong paw first and then we'll fix it with the right paw.
De-den!
Huh?
Well, you know, it's good to go out and enjoy the beautiful sky, but I... I don't know if I feel that motivated to go out for a walk with the sun like that.
Kinda looks pretty nasty though, you know?
Nasty, huh?
Yeah.
What do you think, hololive?
He's become the sun.
I know.
Are we gonna let him be the sun?
It's okay.
Don't look directly at him.
I think that's a good idea.
Your eyes, they'll just be gone.
The sun god, Pero.
Pero's demon dog, Ruffians.
In extra sunscreen.
It's burning!
Praise the sun.
What type of SPF do you need to deal with this?
Pero... What's the last one?
Huh?
SPF.
Sun.
Pero... Huh?
What's the word?
Wow, it seems like Ruffians!
Well, you know you got your SPF.
You know, as long, I guess, you know, if the sun...
If it makes you happy like this, you know you want to go outside.
If that gets you going, get some movement into your day!
Exercise!
All that!
I mean, I prefer it just to be the sun we're used to.
But you know, maybe this way.
It'll mean that summer won't be super duper hot!
Yeah, I guess.
We could allow Pero to be the sun if that's the case.
Yeah?
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, would you ask Pero to put suntan lotion on you with his tongue?
Whatever motivates you.
BAU BAU!
Hello!
Ruffians, this is good news!
Advent, we're very close to reaching our milestone!
Advent, our cover of Team Tomodachi is just about at 7 million views on YouTube!
7 million FUWAMOCO fans!
It came out about 3 months ago.
But I guess it's clear that you really like the Adventrix.
Thank you FUWAMOCO!
You know, it was a very surprising song choice.
But compared to my newest cover, you know where we become childish.
Ai wo Torimodose!
Which one do you think was more surprising, both of you?
Yeah, which one was more surprising?
They're both pretty surprising.
They are.
They're shocking.
Oh good!
You're shocked.
I don't know what this is.
I'm shocked.
Both are surprising.
Are you surprised anymore that Advent does this stuff?
Chabu was the biggest surprise.
I thought it was not so much.
Definitely the buffest.
Yeah.
JoJo!
It's different.
Forget the JoJo.
You're already dead!
Fist of the North Star.
Fist of the North Star!
FUWAMOCO we are really really happy that you're enjoying Advent so much.
And we really hope to be able to release more all together soon too.
Good, yes!
You know, of course FUWAMOCO really likes singing.
You know, the two of us.
But, he really likes singing as a unit altogether too.
So, we'll continue to do our best as Advent!
You are in the way!
And if you haven't yet, please go take another listen to Team Tomodachi!
I'll tell you more about that later.
It's not FUWAMOCO.
But Calli-senpai, she just released a brand new song after her 3D birthday live!
CPR!
BAU BAU!
And you know Calli-senpai, her new music is always a treat, you know?
Always evolving, you know?
But this time, she sang together with another artist named Touboe.
But, you know, Kyai-senpai, she took lyrics and, you know, this time she did the lyrics together with them.
But then sing it obviously.
Obviously.
But you know, then she's like, I'm gonna take a step forward!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
How does her brain work?
But then, you have to ask, how does her brain work?
But then, how does her body work?
I mean, shinigami are just different.
Maybe shinigami are just built different.
No.
Maybe.
Maybe it's because you know that.
Shinigami.
She already has a few deaths.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
Confirm Calli-senpai's built different.
Yeah, we didn't do that.
Did you not submit asking about how Calli-senpai's body works like this?
No matter how many times you ask her, she's not gonna give you the answer.
I don't think she knows either.
It's okay.
It's a banger.
BAU BAU!
She's a hard worker.
Yeah, and much much more.
But you know what?
One cool thing to the next.
Maybe a bit cuter than cool.
Maybe?
For a little while, there's been a very cute project going on in hololive called holoWitch!
Have you heard of it?
Ruffians!
Maybe there's some Ruffians that are like, what is this?
Very cute!
I like witches' hearts!
Well, it's a multimedia project, you know.
Manga!
3D Live!
Anime!
Music!
Yeah, but 3D Live is so cute too!
But you know, our senpai, like Nicochi-senpai, Luna-senpai, you know, everybody.
Everybody here, they become witches together!
You know, the story kind of unfolds from there.
Magical girls!
Yeah!
There has been some changes in recent months of Koe-senpai's departure.
Most recently Shion-senpai will be graduating at the end of this month.
So, wow!
There is some big news!
Just today, it was announced that Fubuki-senpai and Lamy-senpai
Fubuki-senpai and I are now joining as new witches!
Look at them!
They're so cute!
And they both have their own special wands!
Right!
And I'm a little curious, you know.
They're not like the black witches like before now.
Their outfits are similar, but the colors are a bit different, right?
Right!
The tones are a bit different.
I wonder what this is gonna mean, you know?
Yeah!
The brown one's for Fubuki-senpai.
The blue one's for Lamy-senpai.
Gold and silver- Oh!
Maybe that's like that.
Oh!
We missed that!
Maybe we missed that.
We just got the undertone was different, but that makes sense because it's silver.
Are they gonna be extra strong?
We'll have to find out.
Yeah, but I'm ambitious so I'm gonna follow it.
Last time, I tried to watch something.
I had to stop.
It's too cute, you know?
I started crying.
But you know us holo-witches, we're never quite sure what's gonna happen, what troubles we're gonna get into, how the story is going to end up.
So let's keep our eyes on it.
We're really excited to see the world of holo-witches grow.
BAU BAU!
You always cry, Mococo.
No I'm not!
I'm not, okay?
We need twin witches!
I don't know, that might be too much trouble, you know?
It may be mysterious, huh?
Double trouble.
BAU BAU!
If you were taking a look, maybe a couple peeks at our Twitter today, you might have seen that, well, today we paid a little bit of a visit to the doctor.
Just so you know, our breakfast checked out a little bit.
You know, we felt that they've been a bit funny ever since we got sick after fast.
So, you know, we wanted to get a bit of a checkup before it gets any worse.
You know, it's probably a good idea.
How was it?
Well, you know, it's a little bit like we suspected.
They're in a bit of a rough shape right now.
The dog deshita de inflamed.
Pretty inflamed.
But don't worry Ruffians!
I think there's a lot of Ruffians worried on Twitter.
Please don't worry.
It's not super serious or anything.
We can still talk over a game.
The dog deshita too.
And we got a bunch of medicine too.
Moco-chan, you're not excited for the medicine?
Take it properly!
It's just so many different things.
Yeah.
There's this one.
Wait, wait.
I'm gonna count them out.
Okay.
How many questions?
That one, that one, that one.
There's a lot of them, there's a lot of them, yeah.
And you have to take them a lot.
Yeah.
You know, but... It'll be all good and the barkers will be back to barking like normal soon.
And Fuwawa even advised the doctor cause, you know, she's strong enough to take the bitter medicine.
I don't think it's really that bitter at all, so... She was like, are you okay with the bitter medicine?
It's a medicine.
But maybe it's a little bit more bitter than a lot of the Ruffians would expect.
Is it that bitter?
I don't think so.
I'm used to the more bitter.
The bitter medicine.
The bitter, bitter medicine.
Yeah.
Ways to not...
Moco-chan, you had a sip?
Oh, it's fine.
Yeah.
That's so odd.
And this time, I didn't even... I didn't even... No.
Sometimes it can be a bit tricky when a doctor checks out the barker.
Yeah.
I think a lot of... A bit rough.
Other EN Senpai have been going making sure to see the dog too recently.
Get a look at that.
That was really rough.
Moco-chan!
I'm a champ.
You're a champ Moco-chan.
This time I didn't even flinch.
I did really good this time.
Not even you know when it's like...
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
The doctor didn't end up any whiter than usual, right, zo?
So it was all good, right?
Yeah!
But we're really looking forward to how Borko's gonna neglect themselves again soon, so... BAU BAU!
This time...
But!
Ruffians!
You might have seen there's some exciting things happening all across Japan!
Ruffians, you know, if you've ever been to Japan and you've ever heard of some of the cool things in Japan.
You know, konbini, the convenience stores.
The mystical konbini.
And you know, there's a bunch of different ones, but one of the konbini kings is Famima!
Family play!
Right now, there's a special, special, special collaboration going on right now.
Together with Meiji!
About the gummies.
If you get gummies, then you can take home FUWAMOCO!
Like IRyS-senpai, Calli-senpai, or Bae-senpai!
I know what we covered earlier!
You can get special clear files with us for any purchase of the specific... Specific... Specific VT-comi is good!
Actually!
No!
If you're going to FUWAMIMA, you can find acrylic stamps and acrylic keychains outside of FUWAMOCO too!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, I went to Japan!
So we've been seeing a bunch of Ruffians going around hunting us down.
I love BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
This means, you know, FUWAMOCO might not be as far as you think, you know.
But!
We have been seeing Ruffians going on quite an adventure, you know.
To one farming map, another farming map, another farming map, and another sometimes.
Six?
Nine?
Ruffians, we have a special cheat code for you.
Well, if you go to the special website, which is linked on Twitter for the campaign, they do have a list of the stores across Japan that have the acrylic stands.
There is a lot of them.
Quite a lot of them.
But it's not all of them.
So maybe that makes the adventure a little bit easier.
The website has a list of all the stores, so make sure to check it out!
There are a lot of Ruffians looking for an acrylic stand.
You know, that way it's a bit easier.
Oh, I'm going to buy this FUWAMOCO.
Today, FUWAMOCO is a bit bad.
Yeah, so... I didn't know the gummies were going to be delicious.
So, we had a bit of a hard time, didn't we?
So, um... Thank you!
Thank you!
Thank
But they're super cute and of course you know I'm just FUWAMOCO-ing.
Calli-senpai.
Strong baby-senpai.
Ai-senpai.
With a cool energy drink too.
And there's also small acrylic keychains as well that are blind boxes.
If you feel lucky, please try your gear!
We got so lucky!
We got everyone.
I think the next one, if we got the next one, Fuwawa would have been... But by the time we opened the ones we got back, he was definitely gone.
But we were having a bunch of fun eating the gummies too!
Moco-chan, you're hogging the bowl!
I wasn't, but... I dropped them.
We dropped one on the ground, and I was like, okay Moco-chan, I don't want that one.
But I want a gummy, so give me a gummy.
And then I was focused at looking at the cute, you know, the acrylic keychains, and I was like, oh, Kawaii-senpai!
So cute!
So then, I picked up the gummy.
And, I put it, put it back in the bag, and I just pulled it back out and gave it to her.
Yay!
Oh!
Yummy!
This is a good one!
I pretended to put it back in the bag and get a different one.
She wasn't paying attention.
It's her fault.
I can't wait to play!
You know we got all these wonderful acrylic keychains with us, right?
I like sticking them all on.
And you know, if you go on a bit of a search through a bunch of different farming mods, sometimes you find extra treasures too.
Maybe like all the hololive clips, you know, of figures, other yomikomis, you know.
Figures.
Hawaii.
So we hope that my fans, if you're in Japan, if you're planning a trip to Japan, that you hit the FAMIMA and try not to find us there.
FUWAMOCO
It's the middle of the week, Ruffians.
How are you feeling?
Hasn't been a good week so far.
It's better.
A busy one.
Busy.
Spring is starting!
Are you getting ready?
It's been a while.
It could be better.
You've been doing alright.
You have a tummy ache.
Your sister got married!
Congratulations!
I hope that means it's a good week.
I hope so.
Maybe it was rough for you though.
My sister!
But it's basically who I am!
Basically.
Moco-chan, you know, maybe for some Ruffians that have been having a good week, you know, you could give them a pat on the back.
Maybe for some Ruffians that have been having a little bit of a rough week, you could give them a strong pat on the back.
Strong?
Do you need a strong pat on the back, Ruffians?
Yeah.
You ate a burger?
Wow.
It's morning.
Good job.
You need it?
Okay!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's time for another Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
Mococo!
Ruffians!
This here is a wake-up style pup talk!
Because I need you to remember, I need you to know, that you need to stop thinking that you're not good enough.
Okay?
Got it?
Stop thinking that you're not worthy of the good things in your life, okay?
Sometimes I hear you, that you talk down to yourself,
And if you continue to do that, it's gonna make both of us, FUWAMOCO, really, really angry, okay?
Got it?
Huh?
Sure does.
Yeah.
You're amazing!
And you're doing your best!
Of course we all make mistakes sometimes, but you're just on your journey to live life to the best, to the fullest!
And we'll continue together to search for, you know, what makes you happy, what makes you fulfilled.
So let's continue on and remember to be as kind to ourselves as we are to others, okay?
I believe in you!
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Moco-chan for the Pup Talk!
Wake up Pup Talk!
Got it!
Here we go!
BAU BAU!
Well, it's that time of the day!
Another fluffy and fuzzy time of the day, not just because FUWAMOCO's here, but because we have our Doggie of the Day!
Well, today's Doggie of the Day is...
Barbie!
You're so funny!
What the heck!
Hi!
Cute!
Power stance!
You're so cool!
You know, I feel like you know her.
The longer you look at this beautiful picture of Barbie, the funnier it is.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians, what do you think of this weird JoJo pose?
100 push-ups dog, yes!
Wine.
You would say it's wine.
Have a good.
It's like a beautiful painting in a museum.
She's chillin'.
Chillin' in her own way.
I don't know if that's chillin'.
Well, you know, maybe give her a few head pats and then, you know, bobby, bobby maybe.
Give her some treats.
Maybe the jaw lock.
FUWAMOCO-chan!
How does BAU be BAU BAU?
Cute!
Do you need some water, Baby?
It's very powerful.
Powerful?
I don't know if that's how I describe it, but... It's powerful!
Get it!
It'll dry steam!
Bumpy!
She has attitude, she has aura.
But most importantly, she also has a heart of gold.
And she loves to see you smile!
I know.
So please continue to smile.
Walk the dog by her side.
Okay!
BAU BAU!
Cute!
Well, even though you know the song, I might be a little bit suspicious.
Let's see what kind of walks you've been going on, Ruffians!
And today I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
Hi!
Asakura!
Beautiful!
It's a full space party!
I'm so happy that you're able to go out and enjoy such beautiful cherry blossoms.
Look how fluffy they are!
Right!
And you know, together with us and our eggy plushy form.
Eggy form!
Right!
Hi.
Well, we hope you're able to sit down and enjoy them.
We're having something yummy.
Maybe a bit sweet.
Right, you know if you're like busy, you're like, oh, I just, I gotta go, but I gotta take a moment to look at the sakura, but you know, it's even more nice when you can just kinda sit down and just be like, ah.
All right.
So we hope you're able to take a little moment, but
Well, they're still here in Tokyo for a little while longer.
Maybe just a little bit.
A really little bit.
They're almost gone.
But I'm gonna still wish that they stay around.
Yes.
Cause I like it.
It has a ring, this is good.
So you know, let's enjoy them for as long as we can!
I'll enjoy them even when the petals are all on the ground.
I'll just look at the ground then, but it won't quite be the same.
Why are you so beautiful?
They were on the tree at one point and then they fell and that was beautiful too.
And now they're on the ground and they're still beautiful.
Until they kind of get a little bit brown.
Then maybe it's like, okay, now it's over.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Have fun with the fireworks!
And next we have our Question of the Day.
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
I've noticed that Fuwawa sounds like Mococo when she says... No!
Sometimes.
Are you doing it on purpose or do you get used to it just now?
Doing it on purpose, Ruffians?
Huh?
I don't do anything on purpose, Ruffians!
Ruffians!
Do you think we know what we're saying at any moment?
No.
We are not listening to what we say.
95% of the times.
Yeah.
But you know, I don't know.
I just do, I guess, do the same things as Moco-chan sometimes, you know, because that's how things go when you're twins.
We're always together you know, so sometimes we do the same things.
And sometimes we don't do the same things because we're individuals too.
But sometimes it might be similar.
Yeah.
I had to explain that, huh?
What did you say?
Thank you for the annunciation.
I had to explain it again, huh?
BAU BAU!
Is that any better?
I don't know.
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for all your questions, even if they're extra silly.
Your Pero Sightings, even though maybe it's a way to start the day.
Maybe not the right way.
We wanna see your walks!
We wanna see your doggies!
Please send them to us with your hashtag.
With our hashtag!
Don't use our hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
I guess we can share it, Ruffians.
We can share it!
Don't need to fly over it, okay?
FUWAMOCO Thank you all of you!
It's not your hashtag, it's ours!
Our collective was sharing it all together all the way!
Push it!
Okay!
As long as you send us your doggy as a gift, okay?
Yes!
Okay, that's the deal!
You pushed us!
Okay!
It's collective!
Yes!
BAU BAU!
Don't have a schedule out yet this week, but we do have another stream coming up that we have not made our thumbnail yet, so we're gonna be borrowing... De-den!
Shiori!
That means you know!
We're both together with Biboo and Shiori!
Yeah!
I'm a big crowd!
But Nerissa can't join us.
She's working hard, you know.
That's okay.
She wanted to be there.
But she's working hard and we're not gonna distract her.
But we're really looking forward to her joining us again soon.
I'm scared.
It's not a scary game.
I don't know what this game is at all.
I'm expecting... It's a fun game.
Content warning.
It's a fun game, right?
Where, like, little bugs and they're, like, silly?
Right?
Horns out warning?
Well, you two play!
I'm planning to play.
Moco-chan, you're planning to play on your own.
Oh, I didn't discuss it with you, but I was hoping to.
Ah, okie.
It's very silly, that's what I heard, so I'm looking forward to it.
I hope that you'll join Biboo and Shiori on our silly attempt at this game we've born.
BAU BAU!
And just like we mentioned last time, Ruffians, we'll continue to let you know when our next streams are coming up as soon as we can, so please look forward to them.
It's just a little bit of a funny week this week.
BAU BAU!
And for the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU Spring Cleaning!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Mars!
BAU BAU!
Pixel!
Children!
BAU BAU!
Mori!
PJEN!
BAU BAU!
Garinamox!
Jellyfar!
BAU BAU!
We hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!